- If you're going to be good at
something it does take awhile.
Just enjoy the getting there.
What I realized very young is that
I didn't want to live in fear.
Where most people get it wrong
is they're afraid of
losing what they've got.
Anybody who at the age of
60 calls themselves Sting
(audience laughs)
is an idiot.
- He's an English reality TV judge,
entrepreneur and philanthropist.
He's most recognized as
a judge on the TV series
American Idol, X Factor,
and America's Got Talent.
According to the Sunday Times he's one
of the wealthiest people in the UK.
In 2015 he had an estimated net worth
of over 325 million pounds.
He's Simon Cowell and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips.
And as always if Simon says something
that really, really
means something to you,
is really meaningful, please
leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- The good thing about how I made a career
was I was patient.
So I would say to anybody still today,
if you're going to be good at
something it does take awhile.
Just enjoy the getting there.
You're going to get fed up,
you're going to get disheartened
and people are going to
tell you you're useless.
Had all that.
But what I can say after
about 15 or 20 years
I learned how to do something well
and I enjoyed that getting
there as much as being there.
- Let's say you're about
to get out of high school
and you say to yourself
as you said to yourself,
you know what I don't
think I'm college material.
The fear sets in that number one,
if you don't go off to
college then the world's
going to pass you by, that's first of all.
- Yeah.
- Secondly it is if
something's going to happen
I got to make it happen quickly.
I can't afford to spend
four, five, 10 years
in an apprenticeship.
- I think it depends on
what you want in your life.
I mean what I realized very young
is that I didn't want to live in fear.
All my years in school I did live in fear
that if you got something wrong,
they would beat you I mean literally.
So you were kind of nervous.
I was always scared
that I could have a job
which I may not be very good in
and my boss could hate
me and if he hated me
he could fire me and I thought I couldn't
live my life like that so
I kind of prepared myself
to be good at something where I wouldn't
have to have a boss and then
I would only have myself
to answer to and then I wouldn't
live in fear any longer.
And there are times in this
job where you get nervous
or you lose your nerve but I
don't wake up every morning
like I did when I was going to school
or wake up on a Monday
morning feeling sick
'cause I've got to go to school.
So I'm a great believer if
you're not bright at school
and I wasn't clever at school,
you can teach yourself something good
providing you have a good mentor
and providing that you're patient.
- How important is it
to you to be popular?
- Very important.
Whether you're a sportsman
or you're in business
or you know doing what I
do where you make TV shows,
nobody does this to become 77th,
you know you always, always strive
to be more successful
then your competition
and the day that stops
you have to stop doing
this for a living genuinely.
You have to have that drive.
Even as a kid if I was losing monopoly,
I'd tip the board up.
(audience laughs)
- Seriously?
- Oh my God yeah, absolutely
or I'd be the banker and nickel the money
so I would always win.
- So tell me everybody wants
to know why are you leaving?
- Probably for the same reasons you left.
You just know it's time, time's up.
I remember the first year when we did this
and it was like an adventure
and I loved that not
knowing if it was going
to be successful and the buzz,
we were kind of making it up every week.
- Yeah when I interviewed
you after first season
you said I don't know
how long this can go on,
the third season--
- When we first met I
remember thinking at the time
this would be the one
and only time I'm sure
you and I'd ever meet because I'm not sure
we're going to be round much longer.
But I just, i loved that buzz
and I liked the kind of
adventure and it was fun
and then you get to a point
and for whatever reason
two years ago I remember
sitting in the auditions one day
and I thought I think this
is about as far as we can go.
And I've always promised myself
that I'd leave before I was forced to go.
It feels like the right thing to do.
- 13 years ago you were
completely lost, gone.
No money you had five pounds
and have seven dollars left
in your hand, you'd use it for
a taxi back to your parents
and your career in the record business
had just come to a shuddering halt.
And here you are 13 years later,
you're worth hundreds
of millions of dollars,
life's taken a huge turn upwards
but I get the sense with
you that what happened
to you 13 years ago still defines you now.
- Yeah I mean it wasn't the best of times
but then again when I look back on it,
it wasn't the worst of times
because I think particularly
here in Hollywood where
most people get it wrong
is they're afraid of
losing what they've got.
They're just terrified
of losing their fame
as you said power, money,
but actually once you've lost it,
you can always get it back again.
I mean it's not the end of the world,
being ill is worse.
So because I've actually faced what
are most people's worst
fears and recovered from it,
it's not as bad as you think you know?
I didn't lose my confidence.
My friends were still my friends.
I've lived with my parents and
I just saw it as a challenge
that I've got to get myself
back on my feet again.
- What advice do your
parents give you then?
- They were really honest
to God just cool about it.
They were parents.
They just wanted to look after me.
Live with them for awhile.
My Dad lent me some money to pay the bank.
Then eventually I managed
to pay my Dad back.
You know it was what any parent would do
but like I said it wasn't
the worst time of my life.
And actually when I look
back on it now I still smile
because I've bought this beat
up old British sports car
worked 18 hours a day and
I was so determined Piers
just to get it right this time
'cause I knew I'd got it wrong.
So now I found it much
easier to deal with things.
If that wasn't the worst
time of your life what was?
- When my Dad died was
the worst time in my life
as you know you and I have discussed that.
That like getting ill, losing a parent
or losing somebody close to you,
that's the worst thing that
could ever happen in your life.
In all the things that I worry about now,
just trivial, I mean even
the whole kind of Idol,
X Factor thing, I laugh abut it
because it's such a high class problem.
My show's better than your
show but we both got a show.
(laughs)
- It's a bit like Colin
Firth and Hugh Grant
in the fountain in Bridget Jones.
- Exactly
- Fighting you know.
- Over what?
I mean the fact that we're here,
we can do this it's fantastic.
- Do you think the secret to your success
is actually that you are in many ways
in the way you lead your life,
your tastes are quite average,
middle of the road, the kind of stuff
the mass market would like?
- For sure absolutely right.
And I don't think you can make records,
I don't think you can
make TV shows properly
unless you can sit there
as a listener or a viewer.
You can't guess what people like.
It'd be like me guessing
what you want for dinner.
It's impossible.
I can tell you what I want.
So I base everything on my own tastes
and I have fairly broad I
would say quite simple tastes.
I never tried to make my show mean.
It was supposed to be
funnier rather than mean.
- Some of you just say
some of the meanest things
ever seen on American television.
- No and tell you what,
and coming from you,
not intentionally but
you know what we're like.
We have a different sense of humor.
- [Piers] Yeah.
- We look at things in a different way.
I like things to a bit more extreme,
a bit more crazy and I always
felt with the Idol producers
they wanted it to be a
bit more homely and safe
so I think for them now,
they're very, very happy
'cause they can make the show
they want to make now and then I can go
and make the show I want to make.
- [Piers] Will you be
a different character
on X Factor as the one we saw on Idol?
- Like what?
- Can't imagine it.
Those other people trust us
this is what he's really like.
It's not an act.
- No but I was going to say that
that i think that you can't
go on one of these show
and put on an act.
I mean if somebody horrific
is singing in front of you,
I can't sit there and go
take a few more lessons
and come back next year
everything's going to be great
I'm like put this person
out of their misery.
Or it makes me laugh but I do like things
to be really, really extreme
and I like it to be slightly chaotic
and I like it to be controversial.
- How can I make you feel
important in this interview?
- You already have you're sitting here.
I feel important.
- I noticed when you were
saying that the first thing
you try to do is convince the other person
that you're going to
make them feel important.
- It's good that you mention it.
It's something my Dad taught
me when I was very young
and I asked him a question once,
you know how he runs a company
and he said it's very simple.
He said everybody has a sign on their head
that says make me feel important
and it's something I've
always been very aware of
when you make a show and
you've got 150 people on it,
every person on that
show rightly has to feel
that they're acknowledged
for the part they play.
If you start thinking it's all about you,
you've got a big problem.
- Sting recently said the X Factor
is a preposterous show and you have judges
who have no recognizable talent apart
from self promotion and
advising them what to wear
and how to look, it is appalling.
- Well first of all anybody
who at the age of 60
calls themselves Sting
(audience laughs)
is an idiot.
I find those kind of people
who really do live in mansions
who come from quite humble beginnings
and they're living in these stately homes
professing to know
everything about everything
in the world and what the
contestants may or may not feel,
they can say that because
they've got everything
they want in their lives
but what they're really
saying is anybody else
who needs a shot shouldn't
be allowed to do it.
- Have you always lived your life
with this relentless honesty?
- I think so yeah.
I mean when I was young Dan
I got into the music business
via the mail room and you kind of hustle
your way into the main
part of the record company
or the music publishing
companies it was in those days
and you try and work your way up
and the interesting
thing is it's a business
where they invest millions
and millions of dollars
but they give you no training
so when you screw up and
I did in the early days,
I mean I was told in no certain terms
why I'd made a mistake and
I was taught tough love
and in return I try and
do the same thing back
because the worst thing you can do
is particularly when I do a talent show
if somebody comes in with
absolutely no talent whatsoever
and absolutely no chance of a career,
I think it's a crime
to say to these people
well take a couple singing
lessons and it will all work out.
Because it just doesn't work out that way.
- So let me just go to Susan Boyle
why was that one of
your favorite auditions?
- Susan Boyle if I'm being honest with you
on the day I was in such a bad mood,
I just didn't want to be there, bored,
never thought we'd find anyone good,
the second I saw her come out,
I see them from the
right hand side walk out
and I'm like oh my God what we have?
(laughs)
- [Oprah] You were judging
the book by its cover.
- 100 million percent
yes and I also guessed
'cause they're holding the
dreaded hand held microphone,
it's a singer I know this
is going to be terrible
and I was completely
judging the book because
just the way she was walking on I thought
she's either going to tell
jokes or she's going to sing
or even worse a combination of the two.
So I was so not interested.
And the audience were the same.
You know they sat through a long time
they were restless and I
wasn't really listening
to her answers and then
she started to sing
and I thought my God
we've to this so wrong
and then when I watched the clip back
when it was all edited together,
and I saw the whole thing
I actually hated myself.
I mean genuinely.
- You hated yourself?
- Yeah I thought you know
what we're all sneering,
we're not listening to people.
We're judging everybody I
just didn't like what I saw.
- In yourself?
- For sure.
Yeah it was a wake up call
and I was happy that
she made us look stupid.
Genuinely happy 'cause we deserved it.
Seriously I was blown away by that
and I just want to address something.
I know the show is Britain's Got Talent
and you're not from Britain
but I am absolutely honored
that you chose this show
to show us your talent.
I really genuinely am.
(audience cheers)
I think everybody feels the same way.
Always welcome talent wherever
it is around the world
and I genuinely feel privileged
that we've just seen one
of the most amazing things
I've ever seen on this show
you really moved me, fantastic.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Micheala Lynch asked me too.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next
leave it down in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Simon's rules
had the biggest impact on you.
What did you learn most?
What are you going to apply
to your life for business?
What was most eye
opening about this video?
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join
in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Dorma Jean McGruder thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book.
It really, really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love I'll see you soon.
- If you really want to get good,
you're the first in and
you're the last out.
And you listen rather than talking
because if your lucky in life
and your eyes and ears are open,
you may bump into somebody
who can transform your life
'cause they can teach you
but to meet that person
you got to be receptive
if that makes sense.
To do what I do the only thing
that bothers me is whether or
not I'm relevant any longer
because I think if you're
sitting on these shows
but you're not having hit
records or hit artists
in your real life I think
you look a bit of an idiot
so that's all I really care
about Dan is that I can sit
on one of these shows
and justify why I'm there
because in my day job I
am creating hit artists.
Otherwise you're just a judge for hire
which I just couldn't do.